[Music]
my name is spirit ha and you're in luck
because we're playing heaven
this is actually my very first non blind
let's play I love this game I think it's
one of my favorite game of all time it's
it's amazing and since I played Walking
Dead and you bros really loved it
I wanted to play a similar game and this
is probably the first thing that came in
mind I think it will be under a really
good journey I think your brothers will
love it
it's game [ __ ] grills it will touch
your heart it will touch you in
appropriate places but in the end it
will be okay with that and as normal
this son is [ __ ] obnoxious but that's
okay alright and try to keep spoilers
away in the comments I know it's
tempting if you know something and
you're like oh that's gonna happen
Snape's kills Dumbledore but I think
it's more fun I actually played this
knowing what's gonna happen the first
time because someone someone spoil it
but I still enjoyed it a lot so I guess
it shouldn't matter and what's cool is
you get a different ending each time so
I'm looking forward to see what your
ending I will get so even if you watch
someone else let's play it I think it'd
still be pretty cold
yeah now with the choices and things and
the music is beautiful
you can't now I'll shut this happening
again I'm having trouble you can't see
it but I'm having trouble with my
PlayStation it's turning black screen
for me
I'm just gonna pretend I know what's
going on right now I got to pretend
there's a butt in this frame am I
correct
just kidding I actually see the minute
don't you love music [ __ ] about the
music I think music is probably one of
the most important things about games
I'd think about all the games you really
love then you always get reminded how
awesome they are I wanted to see here
the songs are from them in my opinion
like think about Zelda that game would
not be in as awesome if the freaking did
dude I'm just saying I have a good point
here all right oh yeah this is pretty
cool you hold on to and you get to see
whatever take a shower and get dressed
before I go downstairs why did I think
easily said I better take a [ __ ] that's
not good oh there's another for me gone
shopping is up from school at lunchtime
and then I'll come home to get things
ready for Jason's birthday party oh [ __ ]
you weren't too hard I love you all
right you can actually choose if you
want to work or not first time I worked
on the other time I didn't works I don't
know it's [ __ ] I gotta choose
actually as a bud Oh bud are you feeling
everything's alright charlie good bird
Charlie good I'll be on my way now to
the bathroom I think it's over here call
some male other sections nudity in this
game [ __ ]
how do we deal with that Brea's Oh
what a beautiful showering scene music
[Music]
ah come on I don't have
Thank You Christ
[Music]
whatever that was a nice but actually
I'm glad I did this no not again please
please no me okay thank oh that was
close
shake the [ __ ] out of that hair that's
good let's get up all right good job
what is his name again
remember his name I'll [ __ ] it we don't
need a now let's get dressed
press Oh camera all right that's pretty
cool and let's get dressed
let's get funky with it I'm feeling
frisky today I feel like something
exposed like a dress or a ribbon or
maybe or maybe just a pair of jeans I
don't look at me like that oh all right
it's pretty neat granted this game is
not very quick in the beginning we're
just learning how to play right now I
would I would assume it's really awkward
to any enter a room and you have to
change the controller but let's go down
yeah see it's really weird I remember I
had a lot of trouble in with this [ __ ]
I'm holding one direction and then I got
to keep it for a while and then I can
change through the real direction it's
all like tell Wyatt why is that bad day
things hey I think it's almost birthday
Johnny good all right
should we do then I think she left a
note for us if I remember correctly all
right I was supposed to do something the
[ __ ] was I supposed to do
all right
[Music]
yeah close to the left ear come on
you're better than that
yep still having trouble with a thing
what's going on I hear everything all
right a soul
beautiful music holy [ __ ] I'm awesome
it's how I got all the ladies he's being
way too serious about that all right
that's nice I'm really glad I did that
when I was two again I don't know about
you brother but I really like piano
music in the background I think if I
ever had a game I and I wanted to be
piano piano theme day wow wow that's
amazing
like I'm good at all right all right I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing why
don't I remember this oh I'm stupid I
need to I got some time before grace and
the kids get back
better get some work done where is my
office yeah here's my office I'm an
architect that's pretty cool oh I was
actually considering becoming an
architect uh where the [ __ ] are we it's
my grandfather there was an architect I
think my dad would be a great architect
here but that line of profession is over
I got in an architect's goal that's
right but I don't know I spend with
economy which I probably shouldn't have
chosen you should have chosen the
artistic side appear but I we all make
choices in our life there's like video
again and I can't see the screen right
now this is really bugging me a lot I
think I'll play like
[Music]
well that was fun
ah there's something about his face
[Music]
dad no dad that's not exactly growing up
but you're getting there now can I Drive
your car and I don't think you're gonna
have to wait a little while for that why
are kids always always so annoying can
you please help me
No stupid [ __ ] fine
no can I choose not to help her later
[ __ ] oh it's gonna be justified later
in the game don't worry about it
[Laughter]
can I go out and play don't worry about
it Gary what's she talking to she's
crazy
alright it's really funny okay Hey
five minutes boys okay who wants to go
first
birthday boys Ferris all right both have
a turn excellent voice acting I really
like it hello okay shut your [ __ ]
mouth all right all right Jason let's do
the helicopter with your penis that's
really no Kay
whoa and then honestly this is the game
what you're seeing right here this is
the game but it's memorable and nice
even though I [ __ ] hate this a little
boy a bit so that is the game right
there if you're expecting more than that
and you came to hell up okay Jesus
all right what do you want the rocket
what am i doing oh [ __ ] I hate these a
sucking dick in them all right get ready
your watch
Wow you crazy girl oh you're a boy I
forgot what the [ __ ] are you going yeah
that's hilarious
Oh some nice house [ __ ] I should have
become an architect
[Laughter]
okay the giggles becoming crazy right
now all right I put you down hope you
enjoyed it well I have pretty big guns
here hang on all right okay like that
what is that face yeah that's right
yeah yeah no that's just how I roll
that's how I got your mama oh the back
up against all right Oh daddy for your
crimes
surrender weekly say your prayers
four actions require timing press the
indicator alright [ __ ]
flapper X I give up your little total I
got delay on the screen it's not that
[ __ ] easy
oh [ __ ] this is gonna be difficult I
hope I get here kill him come on I'm not
gonna get my ass kicked by this little
[ __ ] I say this I'm not Jesus I'm Jason
now wait what now
I right in the balls if my boss is in my
name oh that's kind of cute yeah
food's ready kids you coming in coming
it's gonna stay that game over roll
credits
no well [ __ ]
sup girl alright so yeah that's what the
game is all about sure I'm not oh [ __ ]
lunch is ready
alright good luck in here okay where's
Sean oh I remember something about the
bird I think is it a cave I spoil it
just kidding Scott says Sean your little
deck
where are ya seriously oh there is kids
kids and games except Clementine what's
up Sean what's up oh it was your only
friends oh my fault
no oh it's not Sean of course it's not
your fault
I'd give anything if you could come back
to life
I get or some things which just have to
happen
even if you don't want that's catch the
theater the theme of the cancer it's not
a coincidence
[Music]
do-do-do-do-do [ __ ] love the music in
this game
[Music]
that's a tonic that's a lot of [ __ ]
pickle
[Music]
I'd like to have a quick look at some
shoes for Sean Jason for a minute I
promise he won't give on sure no problem
[Music]
guys odd we're not going anywhere are we
Jason come on dad I can't wait laughing
already
all right it works with delay it's just
a quick time things that's gonna be a
little [ __ ] I don't think it looks good
guys
Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason J
dates and what are you going seriously
you're pissing me off Jason Jason Jason
I guess you want to check out the class
Jason I'm right [ __ ] here
Jason Jason Jason for [ __ ] where you
going I'm right away you try to pinch me
hey hey little buddy what's your problem
really shouldn't wander off like that
you know or listen terminar [ __ ]
talking
can I have one alright what enough to
have one what yeah it's okay don't yawn
okay let's go sweet I wish it would
sweet like right I can't be sweet to
that DJ what's your name Jason which
balloon would you like Jason ah the red
one clowns freak there you go
that'll be two dollars sir two dollars
for a balloon me for your dad son it's
really crowded in here all right so I'll
just grab my wallet oh [ __ ] it's in my
other pocket
dad just [ __ ] get your wallet man
how can you not feel where it is are you
kidding me I forgot my money I'm trying
dad
oh there they are it is impossible to
try on a pair of shoes with this crowd
where's Jason he was here a second ago I
bought him a hose she turned round he
just disappeared
well they should be easy to spot if he
holds what do you mean disappeared stay
here deportation Jesus crying right back
it's like [ __ ] Jason died exactly soon
Oh Jason dang sorry sir
Oh Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason
oh-ho Jason
Oh Jason Jason I can look down here let
me look down there yes what the [ __ ] we
didn't need to go downstairs now
or I'm gonna lose him in the crowd oh
[ __ ] back up
Jason daddy
whoa there did he have my face it's
ready got it Oh Jason the [ __ ] step out
of my way Jesus this is awesome oh [ __ ]
Jason Jason
you don't see these in game Jason the
same they look all the way solid bed hey
what do you want hey girl what's up
Jason
oh there is
okay he's over there I'm sorry
okay Jason step out of the way you said
hey girl hey only [ __ ] sorry
[Music]
[ __ ] it
all right thanks Endicott
the ring name I thought she's but it
[ __ ] are you Jason
Oh Oh No something's about to happen
they were the same t-shirts
[Music]
jaysis cries out of my way [ __ ] Jason
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no Jason it's
dangerous oh [ __ ] Oh No hey hey don't
run over this right Jason
oh and here comes the music beautiful
game I hate her hate that actress I know
who she is right below this give me a
mini game and I would be happy here but
they get so much better
I love this game it's beautiful
you can't say it's not beautiful so glad
I played this again
holy [ __ ] I really hope you bros want to
see more of this I'm I'm gonna upload it
anyway good just kidding I wouldn't have
it anyway
like infinite if you enjoyed it we
really appreciated since engine you
serious helps me out a lot you know
anyone that just stay awesome breath you
know I love you
you